l'écuyer a retrouvé sa voix envoûtante
l'académie équestre de versailles a
repris le spectacle imaginé par bartabas
en 2003 ne cesse d'évoluer
en 2011 nous avons travaillé avec
carolyn carlson pour le spectacle we
were horses ou du coup on nous sommes
quasiment tous devenu danseur
nous montons en reine à la ceinture et
nous avons du coup les mains libres
donc depuis cette création nous avons
intégré ce tableau le dressage
traditionnels se mêlent à des
disciplines diverses
[Musique]
au fil des années les écuyers deviennent
ainsi escrimeurs ou encore chanteur la
voie de l'écuyer c'est une mise en scène
d'une relation fusionnelle avec les
chevaux travailler dans le spectacle
équestre ça implique un investissement
quasi totale dans le sens où ou del
chaque journée qu'on passe on doit
consacrer vraiment beaucoup d'écouté et
et aussi beaucoup d'amour et beaucoup
d'attention au cheval qui est notre
outil de travail et qui est notre
compagnon aussi une relation cavaliers
monture à découvrir jusque dans les
coulisses de l'académie une visite avec
un conférencier 83 dates sont prévues
pour l'année 2018
[Musique]
oh